okay in this video we're gonna talk
about what ticket price maximizes
revenue and this is a quadratic word
problem so when I first learned about
these problems they were pretty
challenging but once you see how it
works I think it's gonna be a lot easier
for you so it says the stadium has a
seating capacity of a thousand but when
the ticket price is $30 the attendance
is 400 people for each $1 decrease in
price the attendance increases by 50 so
it kind of makes sense like if you lower
the price then people say oh that's a
good price huh maybe I'm gonna go and so
the attendance goes up right but what
we're trying to figure out is you know
how many of these price decreases do you
have to do to maximize the overall
revenue so let's start off by writing
the revenue equation as a function of
the ticket price now remember revenue is
what it's the number of tickets right
number of tickets times how much each
ticket is so let's see so in this case
how much is a ticket right now a ticket
is $30 okay and how many people are
attending 400 people right but if you
decrease the price by a dollar and I'm
going to write -1 X where X is the
number of $1.00 price decreases the
intendant's is going to go up by 50
times X C if you decrease $2 then 2
times 50 is a hundred it goes up by a
hundred people now there's 500 people
attending ok so now we have our revenue
equation as a function of X the number
of decreases in the price by $1 but
let's go ahead and foil this out so we
have 30 times 400 which is going to be
12,000 we have 30 times 50 which is 1500
X we have negative 400 X and we have
negative 50 x squared let's put this in
descending order so we have negative 50
x squared this comes out to 1,100 X and
plus 12,000
okay so that's our revenue equation
right there that's Part A now Part B
what price maximizes the revenue well
one thing I want to point out this is a
quadratic CX squared but notice the a
value is negative so what does that tell
us the parabola is opening down right so
here's the number of price decreases
here's your revenue and we're trying to
figure out you know this point right
here where it's a maximum point and
because they a values negative it opens
down right so that Maxim is going to be
at that vertex and you know the formula
for finding the vertex x equals negative
B over 2a that'll give us our x
coordinate and that would represent the
number of one dollar price decreases if
we solve for the y coordinate that's
going to give us our revenue so here
we've got let's see a B and C so the
opposite of B over 2a let's put that
over here so negative B would be
negative 1100 over 2 times a which is
negative 50 so that comes out to 1100
over a hundred which is equal to 11 so
what the 11 represents is 11 $1 price
decreases that's what the X is here but
it originally was 30 dollars so if we
decrease it 11 times now the price of a
ticket is going to be $19 and that's
what it was asking for it says for each
$1 decrease what price maximizes the
revenue a $19 ticket price would
maximize the revenue some people might
mistakenly put 11 but that's the number
of price decreases so if you want to see
other word problems involving quadratic
equations like this follow me over to
that video right there where we do
another typical one that's just like
this it involves a region that you're
trying to maximize there if